[Applause]
[Music]
their toe with the king
we got shields versus hammer it's kind
of full what a great shoe versus a
hammer and to be honest with you that's
exactly how they fight one fights like
an impregnable shield while the other
fights like a striking hammer so come to
these questions when we're fighting and
we try to see exactly what can get us at
outcome that we want to get you first
let me address lomachenko fighting
yesterday another in the line of how can
I say Corolla was on it wasn't a gimme
but he's not what's going to push him on
the chain
and this is what happens with greatness
greatness makes good look mediocre so
this is the problem that we're having
here we're having the problem that
lomachenko is making greatness looks so
easy and I know a lot of you guys are
having trouble thinking that he's not
being pushed to the limit that he's are
fighting bums no he's actually not this
guy's actually fighting the best of the
best so he's calling out the best of the
best wants to fight Mikey that's great
and I think Mikey Garcia should afford
him but see what Mikey Garcia did was he
went up and chased at our offense dollar
knowing that lone mode will always be on
the table then come back down and fight
Lomo so he in looser else Vince doesn't
matter he wins ridiculous but the lost
alone was the one who's gonna end this
career I think it almost too fast too
furious too crazy I think he's too
intelligent I think he's too elusive I
think he strikes with the same amount of
power from the first round to the
twelfth round and that's what
discourages people they wait for his
power - it took a bit but it doesn't
so we got fights on deck but right now
we're gonna talk about shields versus
hammer I really wasn't gonna cover this
fight shout out the black magic
that's right cuz oh I see you um this
video of BAM
I didn't think that this fight was
worthy of my time basically because I
don't feel that Shields is at that peak
yet um you know we had our Christy
Martin
we had Laila Ali and we had an wolf
those are these female grapes those are
if you don't know
female grapes then go look up those
names but look at their fights the
problem with that is um it's - feeling
too far between so I wasn't intrigued by
this fight as much until I started
digging deep remember I'm only gonna
bring you what I care about all right so
this self is this channel is completely
100% selfish um we don't like it so what
but tune in for my insight to give you
the insightful when you're watching a
fight you know what to talk about you
know points to look for so I'm going
into this fight I'm like and I'm like
you know Clarissa does she I thought she
was just gonna overwhelm this girl woman
and um to be particularly honest I have
a theories on woman boxing I actually
think women boxing they should use
lighter gloves they shouldn't use the
same size men gloves I feel like after a
period of time the punch is turned into
slaps the fights aren't as crisp and
clean and if you want to get to that
crisp and clean nature of fighting
besides the training besides training
and inmates on sex is like a man to
achieve styles like a man but that's
what these women want they want to be
considered you want to make the same
amount of money
to be in the realm of the men and as
mentioned as greats and stuff like that
so that's my opinion of it I think you
lower the weight of the gloves you get a
better and more action-packed fights in
and start getting those knockouts and
those stuff like that
to change the way it is you can't look
at the support the same alright so back
to the fight hammer she she has a great
one too she has a great left hook and
she knows how to box
I saw weighing how fighters are by how
they do when they get hit that's how you
know what you got and you got a fighter
when they get hit you're they get
rattled let me hold on they look
bewildered or do they stand there fight
trade back and try to get back into
position
remember this is competition here at all
times this is a fight this is exactly
what you're trying to see from your
fighter does he have that dog does he
have that grit does he have that bite
down
can he get inside can he can't give you
he or she give you that bang for that
buck that dollar right so we all know
shields have distance pace
Caressa is a absolute animal and that's
only because she trains with men that's
only because she's chasing greatness
that's only because she wants to stamp
her name in that book when it's all said
and done she wants to be and she wants
to go down as the greatest of all time
and now Leila Lee has paved a long way
for women boxing and that's going to be
the overshadowing cloud that st. closes
way what we don't want for this fight to
be is a short burst now being that these
women go to distance is going to be a
12-round fight
what type of 12-round fight will we see
is up to the combatants
I truly believe that Clarissa
shoutout to Andre Ward which nailed it
um do hug grit her determination through
her fight through her
I never say die attitude that's gonna
push it that's going to push this fight
she's gonna throw these shots at hammer
that's going to push her through si
hammer wants to jab hammer wants the
right hand hammer wants to counter
hammer needs space to operate and I
think shields establishes her jab by
cutting the distance hammers not as tall
as you think she is
they stood next to each other and I saw
shields I'm their shoulder to shoulder
almost now that that changes when you
get into boxing stamps you know you dip
down you lose the inch the same thing
happens for a hammer
unless she fights tall and if you
fighting tall that means you got your
head up there and if you got your head
up there guess who's gonna knock your
head off because her right hand shields
right hand is hot best punch why I feel
hammers right jab is our best punch so
we're gonna be in for one of those
tactical give-and-take bouts they may
get sloppy at times because that's due
to the weight of the gloves
they both weighed in at the middle make
the the middleweight weight limit that
wasn't anticipating this fight I wasn't
even gonna talk about this fight but
after digging deep and watching it I
think we're gonna be in for one hell of
a fight it'll be a lot more than that
Norma chenko full round blast of Corolla
like we didn't think that was gonna
happen
so hopefully we can get a chance
to get what we want out of this a woman
great battle these women deserve it
I hope these women bringing the best out
of each other oh we get a split decision
I hope they got to do it again
boom you heard me I hope we get a split
decision that there's such controversy
that they got to do it again so they can
get paid some more I hope it's that damn
good
[Music]
but regardless to what I'm gonna go with
our shields pushing the fight I think
Shields is going to push this fight
I think hammers gonna be on our back
foot the whole night jabbing put on the
right hands when she can I'm possibly
sneaking and a lot of folks here in
there she has the posture of a fighter
that she has the grit determination we
know Larissa has all of those will be
above posture the determination and the
skill can you check all those boxes for
hammer combat talk with the King catch
you guys tomorrow and I LP 1 p.m.
when we go over the results of the fight
see us over there like follow subscribe
we can get all that combat talk
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]